first of all I just want to say thanks
Travis and everyone at PI data for
inviting me to speak again always I've
always learned a lot at this conference
when I first started coming to it so I'm
very happy to be able to hopefully say a
few things that somebody else might find
interesting and useful if you could give
me a cut off time like a five-minute cut
of time somebody could wave cool thank
you so sort of following the last talk
is I suppose in some ways I'm going to
talk about why when and why not to use a
cluster despite the fact that I
certainly work a lot with distributive
systems there are certain problems that
that I work on where I think that sort
of a large distributive infrastructure
approaches really is really too big of a
hammer it's a big of a tool for the job
and there you know the essential of the
philosophy is to just think about you
know writing better code profiling a
code and you know solving the problem
with a simplest solution as possible as
simple as to responsible and one one
type of problem end up working quite a
bit all quite a bit on is sort of in the
world of text processing and natural
language processing I mean it's a big
it's a big world and I'm just going to
sort of give you a few examples of the
types of things that I do on a weekly
basis and sort of why I started thinking
about these problems from from this
angle so sort of here's a brief outline
I don't think we'll get through all of
it but will certainly get through one
two and three and they're they're sort
of the the outline essentially speaks of
itself and the problem is you end up
solving the problems you solve
everywhere you know the limited memory
problem trying to make things actually
faster and appropriate and then sort of
working with other ecosystems that you
need to work on outside of the Python
you mrs. so introduction so a couple of
things I work on quite a bit I I run a
team with Columbia which which is tasked
with building an archival full stock
digital
so rethinking the way that people
interact with large collections of
documents in this particular case it's a
it's large collections of historical
documents which have been released by
the government either through a
declassification or through a FOIA
procedure and essentially of historians
and journalists and political scientists
who are interested in about learning
what's in there and being able to do
research so you end up building you know
the entire adventura pretty much
building the entire sort of data
structuring backhand you know API the UI
I didn't write that and all the sort of
statistical analysis tools which allow
for people to interact with this
information intelligently a lot of the
stuff I do quit quite regularly I work a
lot in law in the law sector and sort of
lawyers quite quite a while ago figured
out that that they're essentially
overwhelmed in terms of the numbers of
documents they have to deal with right
but once again like if we think about
the volume here we're not talking about
large data volumes right this is not web
volumes this is not Google this is not
these are not the problems we think
about when we think about Hadoop or a
lot of distributive systems but these
are simply problems where you know we're
dealing with 10 million documents or 5
million documents and and the structure
and it's more of a structural problem
than a data volume problem but
nonetheless you still have to think
about memory right because you can't you
need to be able to work with these
things quickly and produce results I
also think quite a bit about sort of
human you know the human-computer
interaction side with respect to textual
information right your interaction with
your email people's interactions with
you know personal personally stored
information also with archival
information as well so then developing a
lot of semantic filtering tools and and
document management tools as well so you
know what what ends up happening well a
lot of time what ends up happening is
that you your data comes in in some sort
of a format if you're very very lucky
it'll come in some rocks ml format even
if you're exceptionally lucky it will
never be a consistent format it always
be issues with it right so you end up
writing quite a bit of parsers quite a
number of parsers which are
computationally intensive
so that you can take something that
looks like this which is more or less
nice and be able to have something like
this which is a return of some API call
which you can actually use or user
interface can use or some developers can
use to you know figure out what's
happening in this collection um if
you're unlucky it doesn't look like this
it looks just like a blob of text and
you end up writing the parsers to deal
with that right so you know what kind of
questions do people end up asking so
that's not too abstract you know people
want to look at network interaction
questions so here's an example from from
the Columbia project it's a very simple
plot of just how many times Kissinger
was you know sending tell cons having
these telephone conversations at any
given time and people really like this
stuff because these spikes actually are
informative some of these spikes are
like the you know six-day war some of
them they correspond to historical
events right so these are just very very
simple tools that a lot of times lead to
kind of nice anomaly detection or nice
tools for humans to be able to start
interacting with a large collection and
finding things that are in there but all
of these things require you to have
started with raw text for example this
kissinger collection there's a bunch of
raw text and be able to parse out dates
right to be able to parse out the body
of the thing to be able to parse out the
metadata and so on and so on and that's
a processing task right and you want to
be able to do that in an intelligent
quick format right this is before any
and data analysis is really done or any
statistics you know on the statistical
side of things there's I do quite a bit
of semantic modeling or topic modeling
or Lda or LSI or any of these latent
latent semantic models to sort of either
look for document similarities or look
for document structure to be able to
inform people what's happening so here's
some State Department cables and some
probabilities of topics and associated
words about of cables coming from
different embassies right so these are
just examples but in order for all of
this to happen a large process happens
beforehand right you know you start with
a large disk of raw text and you end up
something that answers API calls and is
able to
and you're able to do this sort of
statistical processing also a lot of
classification text tasks I'm sure
you've seen require feature extraction
right so here's a classic example you
have a lot of emails you have some legal
case you're trying to figure out whether
these emails are relevant to the case or
not relevant to the case you have some
criteria of relevance you end up running
some large feature extraction task which
eventually gets fed into some
classification task which eventually
spits out your answer right you know
there's metadata extraction there's sort
of feature extraction of different types
so I'm sure you've seen some of these
things and these are the sort of the
types of things I do every day so just
sort of to sum up so a lot of
structuring a lot of information
extraction you know named entity
recognition you know do tagging person
name disambiguation text cleaning
extraction and all the machine learning
the classification lda sentiment
analysis rec systems anomaly detection
and so on and so on and these things can
range from the simplistic of you know
once its structure plot you know
sometimes serious to the more
complicated you know do some lda
analysis build an Lda model use that to
create some sort of a system that will
allow you to explore the the collection
that make sense okay so that's sort of a
flow that I end up working with quite a
bit right start with raw end up
somewhere where it's not raw cool so you
know what's so hard about text
processing in general well you know you
in the end it is quite a bit of
information right you can't just like
fit a large collection of text into
memory right see you can't even fit a
large feature set coming from text into
memory generally speaking so you have to
think about sparse data structures its
language right language has humanly
created language right it has its own
peculiarities that you need to think
about the structure of the data that you
get in its original format is never the
same from collection to collection it's
it's almost never the same within each
collection so you have to deal with that
so you have
and think about how to convert it to
something machine readable sometimes you
get things that are you know image files
and OCR and things like that and sort of
a lot of the tools that we have that
I've seen and I've used in it and sort
of developed an industry have really
been developed for solving large data
problems right and this is not a large
data problem right this is just a
particular type of data problem which
you know in my opinion doesn't require a
large distributive solution it can be
solved really on your laptop or in a
slightly bigger machine or a couple of
machines as long as you think about it I
things like really think about the code
and really think about how you're
implementing and essentially the things
that I find fun about text processing
are more or less exactly the things that
I find hard about it right it's kind of
an open it's an open box how you solve a
lot of these problems like you know what
should a digital archive look like right
now right what of you know the original
you know go to the library and do
archival research or go to the basement
of the cloisters and do archival
research philosophy translates to the
space we're in today right that's that's
an interesting human computer
interaction problem as well as all the
sort of other things I end up working on
okay so how do I think about dealing
with limited memory well I think about
it by getting a nice machine without
spending too much money right machines
are pretty cheap there's a WS this
digital ocean they have amazing SSDs on
their machines right there they're
incredibly cheap as far as I'm concerned
so do we all know these these things I
think by now um and thinking about you
know just think about you know how much
actually these things take right so if
you think about how much text you know
tix text sitting on disk how much is it
going to take in memory if you just try
to load it all up in the memory well you
know it's going to end up taking as much
or or potentially more space and so that
immediately makes you think about
different types of hashing algorithms
different types of data types that you
might want to apply to this problem
right which we'll see in a little bit
think about memory quite a bit right so
we do quite a bit of monitoring right
Ian say is this Ian lying more this is a
screenshot from his because H stop
doesn't work on on my Mac that's a
caveat right H stop tends to give
incorrect results on max if you guys
didn't know that just double check
before you believe it um actually don't
know why I don't know if anyone knows
why but it but it tends to give totally
totally random results as far as as far
as what's actually happening but sort of
everything we do everything we develop
we spend a lot of time a moderate
monitoring memory and thinking about
that but not from a distributive system
sample it more just for a you know how
to make it work on one machine and make
it work quickly and then we stream right
so this is text the one thing that's
really nice about text is that it's
essentially independent right the next
the next item on the list is more or
less independent from the previous item
right and what you're generally doing is
you're extracting this information right
once you're affecting this information
you're extracting it one entity at the
time you cash that information whether
you cash in at a sparse format whether
you write it to disk and so on and so on
you can you can think of these things
independently so you can either things
think of the lines of text is
independent right or you or you can
think of the actual let's say files in
this case so so we'd spend everything we
do this and this and everything that's
in the result library is essentially
just streaming stream optimize the
stream and apply some sort of memory
optimized functions to that straight
right so here's a couple of simple
examples like just streaming by line
here's a little utility function that
you know crawls some directories gets
all the paths and opens up those files
and you do something to those files one
at a time right and so here's a here's a
sort of a Rosetta example so there's a
text file streamer class which takes a
base directory it takes a tokenizer if
you guys know what a tokenizer is it's
something that splits up text into
tokens the simplistic example is basic
words maybe stems maybe salamat eyes
maybe sentences whatever your tokens
might be and essentially
just a very very simple to line
constructs you get a an iterator
function and you can just iterate over
that right so you go for item in my
stream and you have this info stream
which sort of wraps up all the
information you care about you can get
the actual text itself you can get the
tokens you can also get a whole bunch of
other information that's sort of coming
along from this right do the same thing
from database so we have database
streamers both mysql and [ __ ] so
essentially you set up yes stream by
running some query there's very few
constraints on the query it basically
says one of the columns should be named
text um that's basically what it asks
for and then you say okay do the same
thing stream one sort of row at a time
and potentially catch some results so in
this case I had asked for text I had
asked for the document ID and I had
asked for date and to make sure that I
don't have to go back and get the
document ID in the date I can just catch
them along the way and sort of these
classes allow you to do that right does
that make sense right so very simple
stuff so and if you can combine sort of
the above process like a very simplistic
streaming process with some sort of an
online learning algorithm right you can
essentially can you can essentially have
a system that is pretty much infinitely
scalable and easily easy to update right
so you can stream your text as it comes
in you can update your learning
algorithm as well right so you have
these two things that you can control
pretty much independently and you're not
bound to having everything at the same
time right you can just keep learning
keep moving on right so those are the
two things like so stream on the stream
on the processing side on the text
processing side and then stream on the
statistical machine learning side as
well right where the stream here is some
sort of an online algorithm cool so
what's the summary there so monitor
memory stream everything think about
caching what you need along the way
right so you don't have to pass over
twice and when you're talking about huge
feature set
either use sparse data structures or
just reduce the number of features and
there's plenty of statistical techniques
to do that so how do you make things
faster how do we try to make things
faster well you know once again we don't
do anything that I suppose anyone who
develops doesn't do where we just think
about how long these things take right
and the nice thing about Python is that
it allows you to profile and time and
sort understand exactly what's happening
in your code in a multitude of different
ways all of which are useful in their
own right so here's a trivial example
from say the email feature extraction
process above so you got some people who
are trying to steal some money and or
something along the way and we'd like to
just tokenize this text so later on we
can extract some of these features and
tokens and do some classification right
so here's a simple task what we're going
to do we have some stop words we have
some punctuation we're going to split
split on the on on the comma or we're
going to potentially get rid of all the
punctuation and so on and so on right
this is a very standard technique so
what's the first thing you might write
you might write a very very simple sort
of tokenize function tokenization
function which might look like this it
has a bunch of loops in it of course you
know you've written a bunch of these
things you already claimed you already
know that this is not going to be
incredibly efficient but this is a
perfectly fine first pass you run that
basically checks whether something is a
punctuation that it leaves that out if
it's not in otherwise it splits up and
gives you back the words right so then
you run it and you test it and you see
that you got some sort of a unacceptable
duration for how long it took to run if
you're going to do this on very very
large documents and millions of
documents this is going to take forever
so you start to think about how you
would want to change that well the first
thing you probably want to think about
is getting rid of this this check write
this for loop for this punctuation check
right that's less clearly going to be
taking up a bunch of time even without
profile
the code you can kind of see that um
natural thing to do is just you know
substitute all you know as much as
possible of these checks with some sort
of regular expression right that's a
fast that libraries pretty fast in
Python it can solve a lot of your
problems if you can translate what
you're trying to do with the text with a
regular expression match or search
function you run that again you get
something faster and then you start to
profile right so you have really really
amazing profilers in Python both memory
profilers and time profiles and so on
and so on and so we could run you know
decorate anything we want with a profile
decorator and then run and just see how
long it takes right so it's pretty clear
here we have this look up on line 62
which is taking the most time right so
we have that look up okay so let's try
to fix that as the next problem what's
the issue well we're looking something
up well what are we looking up we're
looking something that's a string up in
a list of strings right so maybe that's
the problem what can we do that better
and realistically speaking yes we can do
that better you know if you use a set
right set lookup is a one so that's
going to be inherently faster than a
list look up and that reduces your time
significantly right so this is not you
know a developer example this is just a
simplistic example which which which
takes almost no time to do and you could
arrive from start to finish and from
your first pass to you know your later
passes then you know 10 15 minutes but
it can make a huge difference in your
overall process right so here's here's
another way to time things right and I
Python and so and so on okay and sort of
you can convince yourself that you're
actually solving the problem correctly
by changing the data structure from a
list to set by doing a simple simple
test right so this is by far not you
know a brilliant code and this is by far
not the best way to optimize this there
many more things you can do but this is
just a very very simple process which
which we use a lot and which actually
kind of gives back quite a bit as well
so and also we think quite a bit about
data structures right you know the the
data structure is really bound to what
you're trying to do with it right the
there's a lot of convenient data
structures out there you know pandas as
amazing amazing you know built-in data
structures that allow you for great you
know it's the disco manipulation and
whatnot but you know for every single
task that you have at hand it it it
makes sense to spend quite a bit of time
thinking about what actual data
structure you want to use for it right
because realistically speaking you might
be just losing a lot of time right am I
losing a lot of time in losing a lot of
memory because the data structure
carries a lot of weight for it with it
that you actually don't need for your
computations right so there's a great
post by Sally escucho asked us and which
I learned quite a bit from and it's it's
it's very easy to read and explains very
nicely about these things and a lot of
the time you can simply take your
favorite data structure like a Python
dictionary and replace it with a simple
one that's more lightweight that does
exactly what you want and and and and
takes care of it from so also as
mentioned before a lot of these tasks
whether it's the data processing tasks
or the feature extraction tasks they're
essentially embarrassingly parallel
right because everything is independent
of everything else right so this leads
to very very sort of easy
parallelization you know whatever
paralyzation techniques you know of
apply here right and so Python of course
once again has has really great
libraries for this the multiprocessing
library here's a very very small example
right which spins up for sub processes
it's just a few lines of code there are
some issues with this right I mean you
have to think about what happens if you
are dealing with functions of more than
variable you can't pickle every function
right you can't debug as easily write it
if you spin up for processes and you try
to it's not possible to actually debug
and step through so what we ended up
doing is just writing some pretty simple
wrappers for all of this stuff that
allow you to just interact with it a
little bit easier so here's a map easy
wrapper that Ian wrote which basically
does nothing if your number of jobs is
one so that allows you to do all your
debugging as you usually do it and then
it runs it spins up a pool as you need
spins up a parallel process as you need
it alright so this this is actually just
incredibly convenient it also you allows
you to exit with ctrl C instead of like
having to kill the whole thing right um
also there's a couple of other utilities
such as the imap easy function and
Rosetta which allows you to send out and
return jobs and chunks right it also
allows you t debug I there's some
control C escape issues but it's but
essentially what you're able to do is
you're able to take a function you take
an iterable you say the number of jobs
you say the chunk size which you can
optimize depending on your process and
then you just press go you debug it when
you setting at a number of jobs equal to
one and and after that you just let it
go okay so all of these things can just
be found in Roseto parallel and so
what's the sum up so use regular
expressions whenever you're doing sort
of text manipulation unless you really
certain you're going to do something
better use the right data structures
profile your code to death we profile it
all the time multiprocess because a lot
of the stuff is embarrassingly parallel
so that that applies and just note that
a number of the Rosetta streamers they
just have a multiprocessing rapper as
part of it so for example the text file
streamer and the MySQL streamer you know
say i take the mysql streamer i give it
the database connection parameters i
give it the query i care about i give it
the you know the results i want to cache
along the way and then i just give it a
parameter like njobs equals to 3 or
minus
whatever it will paralyze the task for
you all right so that's all built in so
you don't have to do that work yourself
not all the methods are paralyzed right
some of them don't don't Leeza Lee lead
to it or some of them you know we
couldn't exactly imagine the precisely
the context for the user so you know
they're left as is but the
parallelization utility functions can
easily be could easily wrap whatever you
need there as well ok so you can find
all of that into streamers um and of
course like everything I just said you
know I'm talking about Python I'm
talking about rosetta but realistically
speaking the the framework and the
approach applies and pretty much any
situation right he has nothing to do
with Python to begin with right I just
think its own powerful and convenient
ecosystem for work out okay so I have
Travis how much time to it I'm overtime
ok so we're going to skip this I was
just going to say two things there's you
know for a lot of the statistical
modeling that we do we end up stepping
outside the Python ecosystem so there's
a brilliant library for example Caldwell
rabbit very very fast for lda and other
side topic modeling and we wrote you
know and our approach there is not to
you know right rappers for this library
put to right converters so you process
your you know you process your
information Python it out outputs it in
the in the format that the library is
interested in the library you do
something in that library you know
whatever you run your command line C
process and then you have a python class
which is able to read the output of that
so you can work back in your Python
environment right so instead of wrapping
it with some sort of a subprocess call
all we do is we translate to the format
that library is interested in translate
back and and and that works pretty well
so there's a bunch of vocal wabbit LD a
sort of translation functions that are
built in which which make life a lot
easier I think when you're dealing this
sort of stuff so here's the
skip that so here's the summary so you
pay attention to memory you pay
attention to data structures you profile
all the time parallelization is really
easy here so do it and use Python use
unix because these are really great for
text and we also write a lot of command
line utilities because we think that's a
nice way to sort of make this thing much
more useful and usable for everyone so
here's a little bit about projects and
so take a look at the library please
fork it clone it use it contribute there
are many more things that can be done
thank you